jean reno bon ou pas bon à part moi à
fonctionne bien oui ça marche bien c'est
un grand film sur bangui comptant que
sur le premier ça je ne sais pas ce que
le premier était quand même assez plus
que comique était jubilatoire celui là
je sais qu'il est comique est beaucoup
plus grand du fait des informations de
l'histoire qu'on a récolté du premier
quai puisque c'est la suite de
l'histoire n'est ce pas on recommence
exactement à la fin du premier et donc
on a plus d'informations les auteurs ont
plus d'informations les acteurs et les
personnages les vues il ya deux jours
jusqu en fait de fil de films a été fini
de monter fusée oui à settat et j'ai vu
un grand film j'ai beaucoup ri j'avais
la même impression au premier j'avais
rires je savais pas que c'était un film
jubilatoire ça j'ai découvert avec le
public et muriel robin après valérie
lemercier ça ça casse pas le ton un peu
de ce film et que la vieille série
l'homme comme l'histoire recommence
exactement à la fin de l'autre si vous
voulez je n'ai pas vu ce passage très
honnêtement elle est là elle et ça
démarre au moyen-âge elle est là avec
ses coiffes et puis paf c'est freiner
goukoye plus que plus qu'autre chose
pour moi je crois que le film est plus
fort que les acteurs la question que
j'aurais peut-être dû vous poser en
premier c'est est ce que le film sortira
bien mercredi parce que vous avez fini
effectivement sur les chapeaux de roue
et on faisait allusion aux ennuis de
dernière minute qui ont empêché
notamment beaucoup de gens de le voir
villégier non monsieur on l'a vu parce
que comme il faut que l'on parle il
fallait bien qu'on voie un moment donné
puis je marie nous la présenter mais ce
que je sais c'est que le laboratoire a
tourné vingt-quatre heures sur
vingt-quatre puisqu'il faut tirer 500
copies et en ce moment on parle mais les
copies ce tir parce que c'est une
opération qui dure plusieurs jours
s'habitue à la c5 et des problèmes de
mixage de musique c'est pour ça qu'on a
gardé parce qu'il y avait des effets
spéciaux qui sont arrivés au dernier
moment et donc le mit le mixage cph le
dernier mot vous êtes aussi en tournage
à paris en ce moment vous avez pas trop
difficile pour un seul homme
assumer et la sortie d'un film très
attendu puisqu'on l'attend effectivement
et ce tournage lors et grâce à dieu
c'est dimanche donc je vais venir vous
voir et merci de me recevoir
non mais je tourne avec deux niveaux un
film de frankenheimer et c'est vrai que
là
mercredi approche et je suis assez
nerveux j'aimerais que les gens soient
contents
oui ça se passe bien avec de niro
j'imagine très bien avec tous les
américains de façon générale tous les
disques chez un acteur cool je sais pas
exactement ce que ça veut dire mais en
tout cas oui ça marche bien ce n'est pas
trop parler cet aspect là des choses est
de votre carrière c'est pas une
parenthèse quand même l'aventuré avec le
cinéma américain
non là en ce moment évidemment ça prend
des proportions un peu plus fort puisque
j'ai fait l'été dernier godzilla avec
les gens qui ont fait une dépanneuse t
on va voir mais je ne partirai pas quoi
si c'est la question c'est ça je
resterai ici mais mon pays c'est la
france ça c'est que on va on va revenir
un instant effectivement sur les
visiteurs de pardon les couloirs du le
tournage effectivement dans la vue
quelques images s'est promené un peu et
est partout il y avait une réflexion que
j'avais lu et entendu les legends
connaissez par coeur les rayonnages les
répliques c'est qu'effectivement il ya
une série qui vient de se créer
qu'obligatoirement y aura un numéro 3
par exemple
je ne sais pas seulement qu'on aura
j'allais dire avec le public la semaine
qui vient
mais en tout cas ce que je peux dire que
j'ai été très étonné abbaye nagios
lonato qu'on a vu un château
magnifiquement conservés qui est assez
visité du 12e siècle on a construit
autour un petit peu de décor autour de
la basse cour et les gens découper les
morceaux du décor bleu pour l'emporter à
la maison quoi ces petits morceaux là
est donc là vous vous dites c'est que
vraiment le film a vraiment beaucoup
plus quoi j'ai une jubilatoire un
phénomène quelque part oui ces sites
énorme j'ai été assez magique ne sais
pas si ça va recommencer mais en tout
cas pour nous ça a été magique à ce
moment là merci jean reno nous avoir
rendu les il est ressorti de vaud
coulisses merci mais je